there's all kinds of information
available now with the internet it's so
much you know easier than it was then so
it's out there to be taken and it isn't
necessary to pay thirty or thirty-five
thousand dollars a year to go to some
big-name school to get the education at
all cuz over the next ten years nearly
half of all new jobs are going to
require a level of education that goes
beyond a high school degree what's that
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent
adds something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so to help you on your
journey today we're gonna look at is an
expensive education worth it
also if you want to know what Warren
Buffett and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
free video that is 30 seconds to 5
minutes long to help you build your
confidence the link is in the
description below you will move in the
direction of the people that you
associate with so I it's important to
associate with people that are better
than yourself and actually the most
important decision many of you may not
all of you will be the spouse you're
choosing and you really you want to
associate with people who are the kind
of person you'd like to be in my
experience in business there is very
little difference if any between a very
high priced business education and
what's available a lot for a lot less
money so I I went to the University of
Nebraska of Lincoln my last year in
college I went to Wharton for a couple
of years before that I learned just as
much University abrasca as I did at
Wharton at and there's nothing against
Wharton um he's just we had a very good
school there I had some terrific
professors that at Lincoln
and so I would not assume that if I was
paying a few thousand dollars for an
education here in the state for example
versus paying huge amounts elsewhere
that it was going to make a lot of
difference most a lot of the education
you need to be prodded in the right
direction but an awful lot of it is self
the self taught done I mean Andrew
Carnegie did a wonderful thing in this
country in terms of libraries and I used
to spend a lot of time allows I think
I've locked in at the University of
Omaha one what was then the University
of Omaha and they had I couldn't get out
for hours and one night they got so
entranced with what I was reading but it
there's there's all kinds of information
available now with the internet it's so
much you know easier than it was then so
it's out there to be taken and it isn't
necessary to pay thirty or thirty-five
thousand dollars a year to go to some
big-name school to get the education at
all I mean if you're gonna learn
accounting it's gonna which is the
probably the most important course you
take in business you're gonna learn to
count you learn accounting absolutely as
well and my view going to you and always
going to Harvard I mean I see here I
would have bet on that and so I wouldn't
rob huge bills in terms of getting a
business education now you know if
you're gonna get a medical education I
mean there's certain professions where
that there may not be any way around
spending a fair amount of money and
getting in debt to some degree even got
to make that decision yourself but I'd
certainly try to minimize it and and I
would sort of I would haven't figured
out how I would handle that debt and say
a five year period after I got out of
school or I would think twice about
incurring it the single most important
thing companies are looking for our
highly skilled highly educated workers
that's
that's what they're looking for more
than ever before companies hire where
the talent is now I want all the young
people here to listen because over the
next 10 years nearly half of all new
jobs are going to require a level of
education that goes beyond a high school
degree so first of all you can't drop
out you can't even think about dropping
out can't even think about dropping
but it's not going to be enough just to
graduate from high school you're going
to need some additional education and a
good education equals a good job
now I've got two very special bonus
clips from Buffett and Obama on how to
not sleepwalk through life and how to do
something extraordinary that I think
you're really gonna enjoy but before
that I'd love to know what do you think
who do you agree with do you think an
expensive education is worth it or not
let us know share it in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
I advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job
I mean don't sleep walk through life and
don't don't say it's all gonna be great
you know I'll do this and I'll do that
you know I'm just marking time don't
need to be older that I've told people
that's like saving up sex for your old
age I mean it just is not it it's not a
good idea yeah what are you urging them
to do is what I'm talking about it just
yeah you really want to be doing what
you love doing and you can't necessarily
find it on your first job right but
don't give up before you find it yeah
and I remember in 1979 arriving as a
freshman and doing what freshmen do you
know trying to figure out what courses
are and trying to change your study
habits and trying to identify that food
in the cafeteria what it is and we were
visited on campus by a couple of
gentlemen from South Africa who were
representatives the ANC in 1979-1980 and
they spoke about their efforts to
overcome apartheid and for about an hour
myself and a group of students listened
to these young men who were not much
older than we were describe the
extraordinary struggles they were going
through the sacrifices that were being
made people who were enduring jail and
torture and beatings because they had a
sense that somehow someway justice would
prevail and that that brief meeting I
think in some ways changed my life
because what it told me first of all was
that ordinary people can do
extraordinary things when they're given
opportunity we sometimes think that our
leaders have to be have fancy degrees or
well educated or some public office
somewhere these young men had none of
those things but what they possessed was
a anger over injustice that they were
able to channel in a constructive
positive way and I thought to myself
that they gave me some sense of the
direction that my life might go and so I
became active in the anti-apartheid
movement on campuses and I am not sure
we were particularly effective as I
recall Occidental College continued to
refuse to divest despite the various
protests that we organized the students
I transferred to Columbia and there was
similar resistance on Columbia's campus
but over time I like to think that I was
part of that mosaic that applied
pressure and ultimately helped those in
South Africa achieve the extraordinary
liberation that I would witness almost
ten years later at night as a as a law
student and I remember the image of
Nelson Mandela walking out of prison and
understanding that a seminal moment in
history had occurred and that Mandela's
long march towards freedom was not his
alone but was part of thousands of
footsteps of millions of footsteps of
people all around the world and I traced
back me getting involved in politics to
that moment because I as a consequence
of that organizing on a college campus I
became a community organizer as a
consequence of a community organizer I
after going back to law school became a
civil rights attorney as a consequence
of being a civil rights attorney I
entered the state legislature and I now
stand before you as a United States
Senator and as a candidate for president
and so the primary message I guess I
have in receiving this award is that all
of you represent enormous potential and
enormous possibility for change because
we all know that injustice
still exist to justice it exists here in
the United States in every poor
neighborhood and in every inner city and
every rural community all across the
country there is quiet desperation young
people's lives are filled with sadness
and desperation and anarchy and chaos
and obviously all around the world we
see those same symptoms of hopelessness
made manifest in places like Darfur
places like the Middle East in places
that too often are forgotten about and
not written about until they flare up in
tragedy so I hope that all of you who
are on the brink of doing extraordinary
things decide to channel that talent and
that energy and that imagination to
figuring out how do you move the process
along for a better history you know how
do you put your shoulder against the
wheel and move that Boulder up the hill
and I'm absolutely confident that if all
of you take up that challenge the world
is waiting for you ready to be changed
because I think we live in this moment
in history right now where the hunger
for change the hunger for something new
the desire to break out of the ordinary
the self-interested the petty the
trivial is is everywhere altruistic
world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary v-d-j Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video